[موسيقى]
خلال حقبه شكسبير كان يتم تمثيل الادوار
النسائيه من قبل الرجال على العكس من ذلك
يشارك في تمثيل هذه المسرحيه ممثلات يمنيه
كان عليهن مواجهه المجتمع اليمني شديد
المحافظه لتمثيل شخصيات النسائيه تواجه
بدورها الكثير من الصراعات الوجوديه
جدا
لازم تكون عندها قلب كبير وسعاب حيث انه
تتقبل المجتمع اللي هيبه والمسرحيه مش
مسرحيه سهله ولا مسرحيه نحن نقدر نمشي في
بعل هوانا نحن لازم نمشي على خطوات معينه
ونقاط معينه البيئه الفنيه في اليمن اصبحت
مقيده جدا بسبب الصراع القائم منذ اكثر من
ثمان سنين لكن الفنانين اليمنيين يتعطشون
لاستعاده حياه فنيه ازدهرت في وقت غابر
كالفنانين نتامل
انه تكون في اعمال ثقافيه واعمال مسرحيه
واعمال سينمائيه
بالمستوى الكبير جدا اللي فعلا تبرز
الثقافه الثقافه العدنيه الثقافه اليمنيه
الثقافه الحضرميه الجمهور اليمني متعطش
لتطور الحياه الفنيه ايضا فقد ارهقه
الصراع في اليمن وعان منه بشده نحن شعب
متشوق لهذه الحاجات
ونتمنى ان تتكرر هذه الشغلات واصل يعني
شعب حاسس بيضيق وتعب يعني في يجي يسلي عن
نفسه ويثقف نفسه اكثر ان نهتم في الفن
والموسيقى للنهي من تزرع الحب والسلام في
اليمن هناك رغبه قويه في تنشيط الحياه
الثقافيه في اليمن ان كان من الفنانين ام
من الجمهور هي رغبه بالوجود والبقاء قبل
كل شيء ورغبه في حياه طبيعيه دون صراعات